you can follow him at larry elder larry
elder thanks for being on the show good
sir
my pleasure no the stache is gone long
gone gone but not forgotten
No Mas why why well it's a long story
but I use it the pilla Tori on my face
like a lot of black men because I have
ingrown hairs and one morning I get up
and I put it on too too deeply on one
side and it burned that side so I did
the other side and burn that side
finally I ended up having a little thing
like Hitler oh yeah little bit but
nobody even notice all these years are
19 years old I think my first has passed
all these years seasons I find out
nobody even noticed I didn't take the
time anymore black Hitler where I notice
you know why because I can't grow one
eye so I think it's one of those things
if you don't have it you notice it and
maybe I did all your friends have
glorious stashes so it was just kind of
you know run I think it's a black man
thing if you notice black men uh by
proportion have a lot more mustaches and
white guys do I'm not quite sure why my
dad never did less than most of the guys
in my neighborhood you know growing here
with a cool thing so I always had it and
when I got rid of it I thought that
nobody noticed so now I save about 15
minutes okay you always lie that up why
don't you why don't you have to go
straight to the racial thing goes right
to the racial thing uh well because it
because we got a Supreme Court
nomination happening and FX on race
should you hear about that lawrence
tried as a Harvard professor he says the
reason the Republicans are throwing sand
in the years is because Obama's black
yeah never mind about Obama one of the
filibusters Sam Alito and Obama
apparently is not going to the funeral
of ethanol Scalia so maybe he's got
something against the italian-american
if you want to bring the race card up
well back to the mustaches to if you're
talking about Italian Americans listen
forgive me as a layman you're obviously
a much more informed and well-read
gentleman than me if it's not the
Senate's job to sort of a system this
vetting I'm a little confused as to
their role what's unconstitutional about
this
well the Senate's role is advise and
consent they also be have to vote on the
nominee but there's no rule that
requires them to vote on the nominee let
alone vote on the nominee and a
president named duck year
right and Chuck Schumer in 2007 and
Bush's last year said he wasn't going to
approve any nominees whatsoever rock
obama as i mentioned trying to
filibuster to stop sam alito from even
coming to the floor for a vote
so when the shoes on the other foot
these guys have no problem whatsoever
trying to get their guys to know when
it's not in the yellow screen it's all
politics the bottom line is there will
be no Supreme Court nominee until Obama
is gone it'll be up to the next
president because Republicans won't have
it over their dead body and for the
other way around the Democrats will be
doing the same thing as they've done in
the past over your dead body well then
what you're talking about running
against the Hillary Clinton punishments
must be lost a bit it's quite possible
so okay mr. elder uh this is important
but I also sort of wanted to because you
were really obviously with the Clarence
Thomas thing at the forefront and that
is interesting to sort of go back to
what was the biggest controversy that
because we talk now about all how
politically correct we've gotten what
was this big controversy because it was
on Twitter and there's an entire
generation I know about this and come up
with the coke can and the shortened
curly um there's an entire generation
who doesn't know and so they believe
that Clarence Thomas is a horrible
womanizer and sexual harasser who still
is sitting on the court as brightly as
he can for those dumbasses listening let
them know what the big scandal was about
with Clarence Thomas well first you have
to go back to the prior nominee and that
was Robert Bork right Robert Bork in
1987 was nominated by Ronald Reagan
normally these things don't make any
real difference but work was going to
replace the liberal and the court would
have been shifted 5-4 in favor of the
Conservatives believe it or not Antonin
Scalia arguably the most conservative
justice serving right now was serving
got confirmed unanimously not a single
vote against him right Ruth Bader
Ginsburg very liberal not a single vote
against her nobody cared until all of a
sudden the core was going to shift from
liberal to conservative and then Robert
Bork was nominated and he was called
everything but a child of God he was
defeated on the floor so Bush them is so
silly Reagan said it is another
conservative a black one hopefully that
even the Democrats weren't going to stop
this guy because he would have been the
second black guy to be on the Supreme
Court sure but it turns out that a woman
surface named Anita Hill used to work
for him
blames he sexually harassed her
doodle he apparently hit on her not
physically just made moves on her didn't
touch her and apparently said for some
reason there's a pubic hair on my
because you run through such a serious
series of events she's gotta toss I was
outside there with a straight face and
it's that was what it was it was it was
something like he was like you know kind
of in a break room I was telling not gay
Jared about this he's younger and you
didn't really know the story I said yeah
his big is big sin was he said look at
this so someone's pubic hair on my coke
can and kept on walking and that is a
big thing he just gotten he just gotten
divorced keep apparently lonely it's
getting on this woman at work and this
is his clumsy way of doing it but he
didn't touch her didn't didn't arrest
her
he didn't assault her he didn't rape her
and why this was a big deal only was
because of the politics anyway Clarence
Thomas is there and apparently has not
put a pubic hair on anybody's coke since
then well I wonder if it's a problem
with you was when you had the mustache
if you know that can be confused if you
leave it there and you're doing it
burning it off and you have the half hit
learn you're leaving hairs everywhere so
what's what's this on the cocaine Larry
I hope as a matter of fact they would
hope Larry had taken a sip of your coke
wouldn't you well if it's another thing
I have to worry about if I don't have
this - it's a fact anyway I don't have
his - it is a great hope anymore
well yeah well you know it's funny I
just wanted to briefly touch on that
because he was trending I'm sure you saw
on Twitter or people were praising the
death of Scalia they were you know
thrilled with it listen and I will tell
you I made fun of Ted Kennedy when he
when he died because he killed somebody
so I don't begrudge people for that I
just point out the hypocrisy to the left
demands respect when their people pass
and of course they show on well here's
another level of hypocrisy when when
Scalia died there a whole bunch of
tweets saying what does clarence
comments going to do now that it's
puppet master is dead because they
typically both the same what people are
saying if the clarence thomas is so
stupid he doesn't know what he's doing
until scalia tells them what to do now
this if that's not racist i don't know
what it is what is your problem
you insensitive hole that's what i said
- there there is a magazine Steven that
came out a few years ago it's now the
font called emerge magazine
yeah caricature of Clarence
on the cover of the magazine with him
holding a lantern and the graphic said
Justice Clarence Thomas lawn jockey to
the far right inside the magazines the
black magazine now an air once Avanti
would publish my ebony uh inside the
magazine is a caricature of Clarence
Thomas on his knees shining Antonin
Scalia's shoes yeah well I miss out
these guys roll yeah those in minded
empathetic
non non racist caring we care about
black people
left-wing until there's a black
conservative who of course refutes the
whole narrative that right or oppressed
that the man is still holding effect and
so somebody like Clarence Thomas and if
I may say Larry elder are a direct
breath of that narrative and therefore
we have to be maligned at Uncle Tom's
and sellouts right laps and also that
character is inaccurate because the one
time I've seen Antonin Scalia with a
full shot which I'm sure no doubt
thrilled Dick Morris he was wearing
brushed suede shoes you don't need to
shine though so the left does not care
about accuracy I won't be questioned on
albedo heerlen no they couldn't know
it's funny you may not know this is part
of a full podcast a full three-hour
program that you can hear every week not
only on radio but click the box right
next to me so you can see the full live
version